Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my Thor 5 video
Chris Hemsworth
Taika Waititi
have been talking about it.
There was a behind the scenes book
that a lot of the trades are quoting
now that Thor 5 is in development
at Marvel.
Separately, Chris Hemsworth has also been
talking about his final movie as Thor.
But I think that's meant to be something
separate, like Avengers five,
Qing Dynasty in Avengers six, Secret Wars.
Don't worry. We'll explain everything.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there are a lot of rumors about Marvel
doing like a soft reboot after Avengers
six secret words
like sort of retuning the universe
and recasting people if they need to,
changing back stories that they have to.
they've already rebooted Spider-Man
so many different times
and brought those characters back.
So just imagine like a bigger version
of that in the next 20 years.
What the trains are reporting is Taika
Waititi talking about what they would do
after Thor, Love and Thunder.
And this is his quote.
He says, What's left to do with him
talking about Thor himself
It's got to be something else
that feels like it's carrying on
with the evolution of the character,
but still in a very fun way
and still giving him things
to come up against that
feel like they're building on obstacles
that he has to overcome.
I don't think we can have a villain
that's weaker than HeLa.
I feel like
we need to have a step up from there
and add a villain
that's somehow more formidable.
they've already set up
this arc with Hercules
and the gods going after Thor
trying to kill him.
I'll explain that in a second.
that might wind up
being a completely separate thing
because Taika Waititi was talking
about that recently, saying that
he wasn't going to be involved with that.
we can introduce Hercules
and let's make love this notion of it.
But apparently it is, and
it is.
And I know it's
opening up a whole new thing,
which I love,
but I think maybe for everyone
who loves Greek gods.
Talking more about the lead up
into the next Avengers movies.
That's sort of the beginning of this Kang
Multiverse, new Avengers stuff,
all coming together in a clear way.
Marvel Phase
five is sort of like the march as they
bring them all slowly together
by the end of Marvel.
Phase five,
the beginning of Marvel, Phase six.
There is a version
of the New Avengers team
that'll start to happen in Captain America
four New World Order.
Like the Falcon,
Captain America will slowly start
putting his quote unquote team together.
And that is the new Avengers team.
and currently right now, Thor is one of
the few remaining original core Avengers
I just did a bunch of Captain America
for New World Order in Thunderbolts videos
because there's a big World War Hulk plot,
Big Hulk related plot that's flying
through those with Red Hulk, with Bruce
Banner's Hulk in with Scar, Son of Old.
just in terms of Chris
Hemsworth's character.
We last saw him at the end of Thor, Love
and Thunder end, at the end of that movie
he agreed to raise Gorge resurrected.
Now Super child named Love resurrected
by eternity, the child of eternity.
That's where her superpowers came from.
and they just go on adventures
together around the universe,
helping people giving the movie its title.
They are both love and thunder,
going around helping people.
here's where we start
to get to The plot of the next door movie.
Like Love
will not be a big character in that.
But when the events of the movie pick up,
Thor will still be doing what he's doing
now, going around helping people,
The Jane Foster stuff, Sacrificing herself
and then going to Valhalla when she dies
is also meant to be more of an Avengers
six Secret Wars teaser.
Eventually, she will come back, per
the rules they set up in Moonlight.
I think the reason she ended up there
is because she formed a contract
with the Hammer.
Like even though Moon Knight himself
did not believe in the Egyptian afterlife,
he formed a contract with Concho
to become Moon Knight.
And that's why he wound up in the duel
and as far as I know she heimdall
the original Loki from the 616 Marvel
universe not coming back during Thor five.
It's always possible,
But I think it's meant to be more
of a secret Wars teaser and eventually
we will see versions of them slowly cameo
in other future movies.
some of them won't come back permanently.
Some of them will just be cameos.
But that's the whole reason
why they tease Valhalla
in another dimension, like,
Oh, they're all still here.
They can come back to the main MCU
dimension eventually.
The Hercules Post-Credits
scene is really just about setting up
the next Thor movie.
Not so much about Avengers five,
Qing Dynasty or Avengers six Secret Words,
but Hercules might also appear
in secret words in a cameo to
Because
every character in the history of Marvel
is supposed to have some kind of cameo
in that movie.
Like think the portal scene from Avengers
Endgame times 100.
You want more?
Yes. Yes, we wanted more.
Bring every single character ever.
even Howard The Duck was in
the portal scene in Avengers Endgame.
So if Howard the Duck made it
into the first version of that,
you have to imagine
the most obscure of characters
will probably make it
into the secret wards version of that.
but when Zus tells Hercules to go
kill Thor and creates this larger plan
to make the lesser beings normal people
fear the gods again,
because the whole theme in the movie is
that people have turned away
from the gods.
they also address that during moonlight
as well.
way fewer people across the universe
believe in gods.
So was a way to make the people fear them
again.
Zus is having Hercules
kill Thor in broad daylight, so to speak,
it is more of a Thor versus
all the other Gods kind of movie,
like a War of Realms type of conflict,
a mini version of Avengers
Infinity War in Avengers Endgame,
where it's all about Thor versus
the rest of the gods,
which is kind of funny
because that's kind of what they said.
Thor Love and Thunder up
to be like Gore versus
all of the other gods
during that movie Thor even jokes
about how all the other gods
are going to hate them
and want to kill them now.
Now they're just paying that off like,
oh, yeah, they're definitely coming
to try and kill you
In the comics, Hercules was meant to be
about as powerful as Thor, just like Thor
in the comics too.
He also gained greater cosmic levels
of power to become God of Gods
Rune King Thor is a good example of that,
like Thor becoming the God of all Gods.
That's
how powerful he was during Chaos War.
More recently in the comics, Hercules
also became God of all Gods.
so even though their powers work
very differently,
they're kind of the same power level,
basically.
even if you haven't read a lot of Hercules
comics in the past, MCU Hercules
powers are similar to a lot of the other
pop culture depictions of Hercules.
He starts out as a demigod,
a son of Zeus and a human woman,
and throughout his adventures attains
more power and eventually has to choose
whether to live the rest of his existence
as a full on God,
like hundred percent
God or pull of Thor in Avengers Endgame
and just continue having adventures
on his own on ground level.
Thor's arc in
the MCU has been pretty much that.
Like, do you accept your responsibility
to become king of your people,
become more of an actual
God to your people,
or do you just continue
having fun across the universe
since Chris Hemsworth is saying that
that next Thor movie versus Hercules in
the Gods is meant to be his
last time as the character.
Most people think that means that Hercules
is going to be successful
in killing him, but I don't think that
that's what they're going with.
also, I think the Chris Hemsworth
is being a little misleading
when he's saying he's
leaving the character like Hugh Jackman
left Wolverine after Logan.
Patrick Stewart
also left Professor X after Logan.
But here they are
playing their characters again a lot.
Deadpool three is like a full on Deadpool
and Wolverine movie.
based on countless other examples of stuff
like this happening in previous movies.
my early theory right
now, is that when Hercules
and Thor start the movie battling it out,
eventually they'll have their quote
unquote Martha moment post all the memes
like Thor will convince Hercules
that they're both total pros.
they're the two biggest bimbos
in the Marvel Universe.
Why wouldn't they become drinking pros
at some point they'll have a similar arc
with their relationship in the movies
that they did in the comics.
like when Hercules was first introduced
in the comics,
he became more of a foil for Thor.
They battled it out quite a bit Eventually
they became good friends and just started
having lots of fun together.
Just let's go
round, smash a bunch of alien cultures
and then get really drunk afterwards.
end, by the end of his last movie,
he will accept the greater cosmic role
and become a little bit more like Rune
King Thor in the way he fit within
the Marvel Universe in more of a
God of Gods cosmic kind of role in.
That'll be how they explain
why Thor isn't around day to day
all the time for regular movies anymore,
but how he can still come back for cameos
occasionally in the future
when they really want him.
leaving room for Hercules in the MCU
to eventually fill
Thor's role on that new Avengers team
like he did in the comics.
I honestly they put a chip in my brain
that will explode
if I answer any of your questions.
during the first red
Hulk arc in the comics
which were getting ready for in the MCU.
The incredible Hercules title even took
over for the Thor book in the comics.
a lot of the plot of Qing
Dynasty is based on Avengers
Kang War in the comics,
which is a little bit different.
But a lot of the new Avengers
team in Kang War is the Avengers team
that we're going to see in the MCU.
like Hercules is on the team.
Falcon.
Captain America was on the team,
Spider-Man was on the team.
Spider-Man is still going to be
on the MCU version
of the Avengers team during Avengers
five and Avengers six,
we also have gotten Spider-Man
four before that happens.
So I know there's lots of questions
about what
the spell changed with Spider-Man
and The Avengers.
It didn't change him
fighting with The Avengers
or being on the Avengers team.
They just forgot that Peter Parker is
the person underneath Spider-Man's mask.
they haven't announced any kind of release
date for that Thor versus Hercules
movie that they're setting up or how many
other guys are going to be in that movie
unless they announce that they're starting
work on it next year.
They wouldn't be able to get it out
until after Avengers six Secret Wars.
he will be in Avengers
five and Avengers six Secret Wars.
And then after that they'll do that
Thor versus Hercules movie.
and then after that
he pulls more of a Hugh Jackman
Wolverine, where he only comes back
every once in a while.
the post, all your predictions for that
Thor versus Hercules movie
in the comments below,
who else do you want to see in that movie?
the only other really cool fan favorite
slam dunk characters
you could put him up against that
people will get really hyped about
would be, say, like Galactus, like Thor
versus Galactus or Thor versus Silver
Surfer is a character
that they have introduced yet,
and we know the Silver Surfer
isn't supposed to be in the next Fantastic
Four movie
bigger reminder to my Star Wars
Ahsoka episodes start next week.
They'll be on Tuesdays every week,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
click here for my Deadpool 3 Video
about Channing Tatum coming back
as a version of Gambit in Click
here for My Doctor Strange 3 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!